écoutez nous on souhaite que vous
restiez ici que vous rencontriez un
homme que vous soyez heureuse mais pour
savoir si vous êtes prête à rencontrer
l'homme de votre vie on va voir ce que
vous êtes prête à faire pour lui on va
faire une interview par l'amour une
belle tranche est ce que vous pourriez
passer s'ennuie en bas de chez votre
homme à l'attendre 50
est ce que vous pourriez vous convertir
à une autre religion sans y croire ah
non vous est difficile quand même comme
l'attendait là est ce que vous pourriez
faire des gosses sont les vouloir ah non
si vous répondez dans le secteur ait
jamais trouvé qu'elle était un problème
et je vous voyez vous coiffer comme
catherine lara jusqu'à la fin de votre
carrière
catherine je ne sais pas compris donc il
vaut mieux
franchement il vaut mieux elle se voyait
vous fâcher avec vos parents par amour
un an mais par amour de tes grands
parents
est-ce que par amour pour les supporter
sa belle mère à la maison
ah oui vous êtes d'accord là dessus
complètement donc si un mec belle-mère
un champ pourriez prendre 30 kg de plus
apparemment si chance un ton d'accord
voyez vous m à la drogue apparemment ou
qu'elle est enceinte oui est-ce que par
amour vous pourriez changer de sexe
n'ont jamais changé sac à main jeudi à 5
milliers de civils non non non
est-ce que par aman vous pourriez
supporter des propos racistes à la
maison tous les soirs supporter que la
porte des toilettes reste ouverte par
amour non pas de problème ah ça me
dérange pas ça ne dérange pas vous
pourriez supporter une maîtresse lormont
deux maîtresses
non oui puis je suis parti une caméra
par amour un mec qui aime filmer ses
ébats amoureux à à un toilette en
laissant la porte ouverte version est ce
que vous pourriez supporter un fouet par
mo ou non
bon du coup de foule non elle gagne elle
quand elle est couchée sa peau de bête
devant le feu de cheminée etc et padraig
la foi est un très vieux mais c'est ça
mais en même temps elle est quasi
immédiat différence quand est-ce que par
amour c'est une belle itron pour un
supporter une ceinture de chasteté non à
nous
adacore les clubs échangistes pour
garder oui j'aimerais donc je ne sais
pas pour le citoyen est ce que par amour
pour y devenir son esclave sexuelle
oui c'est très séduisant pour f1
consentante
il ya des trucs sur lesquels elle est
pas belle à la merveille m non on arrive
à la pire question maintenant ayalon
l'asap daniel on lui fait céline
oui parce que par amour vous pourriez
supporter une toute petite [ __ ] week-end
déjà vous verrez bien ce sera
non